[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
موسكو تتصدى لهجوم جديده على بيلجارود
واشنطن تقول ان اوكرانيا جندت عملاء في
روسيا لتنفيذ هجمات بالمسيرات
الجيش السوداني يستعيد قاعده جويه
بالخرطوم والاتحاد الاوروبي يدعو طرفي
الصراع لوقف الاعمال القتاليه فورا
محادثات الليبيين في المغرب تصل الى
نهايتها بانتظار التوقيع على قوانين تسمح
باجراء الانتخابات
الامير هاري يتغيب عن المحكمه في قضيه
انتهاك الصحافه لخصوصيته ويستعد للمثول
غدا في شهاده تاريخيه
قالت مصادره لشبكه سيان ان اوكرانيا جنّت
عملاء بالداخل الروسي لشن هجمات بالمسيرات
من داخل التراب الروسي المصادر ذكرت انكيف
اقامت شبكه من العملاء
والمتعاطفين داخل روسيا تعمل على تنفيذ
هجمات ضد اهداف روسيه شبكه روسيا ان اضافت
ان المسؤولين الامريكيين يعتقدون ان هؤلاء
العملاء الموالين لاوكرانيا داخل روسيا
نفذوا هجوم المسيرات على الكرملين الشهر
الماضي اشارت الشبكه الى انه ليس من
الواضح ما اذا كانت هجمات اخرى قد نفذت
بالفعل في الايام الاخيره من خلالها هؤلاء
العملاء
اكد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه اكد ان واشنطن
لا تشجع اوكرانيا على استخدام الاسلحه
الامريكيه في شن هجمات خارجه حدودها واشار
في مؤتمر صحفي من الهند اشار الى ان
امريكا تراقب استخدام هذه الاسلحه نتابع
كما تعلمون فاننا لا نشجع اوكرانيا على
استخدام اسلحتنا في العمليات الهجوميه في
روسيا وفيما يتعلق بقدرتنا على تتبع
ورقابه استخدام الاسلحه فاننا نواصل
التقدم في هذا المجال اعتقد ان
الاوكرانيين كانوا شفافين حقا في السماح
لنا بالوصول الى تلك المناطق التي نحتاج
البحث فيها وما نود النظر اليه
[موسيقى]
هذا واظهرت مشاهدينا الهجمات الاخيره التي
شنتها داخل العمق الروسي حجم الخلافات بين
قائد فاغنر والقاده العسكريين الروس خلاف
ظهر على هامش معركه باخ مطحمه حينما انتقد
في حينها يفضيني بريجوجين قائد المجموعه
شبه العسكريه طبعا الروسيه انتقد وزير
الدفاع الروسي السرجي بسبب نقص امدادهم
بالذخيره هذا الخلاف ايضا اتسع لاحقا لتصل
اخر محطاته الى بلغرود اتهم بريجوجين
القاده العسكريين الروس بالتقصير في
الدفاع عن المدينه المتاخمه لاوكرانيا
والتي تعرضت كما تحدثنا لقصف وايضا هجمات
مكثفه على مدار ايام قال ان افعال الجيش
توحي برغبه في التنازل عن اراضي في
بريجوجين اكد انه مستعد لارسال وحداته
للدفاع عن تلك المنطقه الروسيه طبعا
المتاخمه لاوكرانيا والتي كما ذكرنا تعرضت
في الايام الاخيره لقصف تعرضت ايضا لهجمات
مكثفه من الجانب الاوكراني بروجين قال اذا
لم توقف وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ما يحدث
هناك في بيلجرود حيث يتم الاستيلاء على
اراضي روسيه فهمنا من الواضح اننا سنتدخل
اذا لم توقف وزاره الدفاع في المستقبل
القريب ما يحدث في منطقه
لان ما يحصل هناك هو استيلاء على اراضي
الاتحاد الروسي والمنطقه لاجل هذا اشدد
على اننا سنذهب الى بالقرود لحمايه شعبنا
الروسي
والمزيد معنى من باريس الخبير العسكري
الجنرال جومينيك ترامكان ومعنى من موسكو
الكسندر كوسنتوف نائب مدير معهد التنبؤ
والتسويه السياسيه لحالات الصراع اهلا
بكما وابدا معك
في قراءتك للمشهد هذا نحن نتخلل نتحدث
عذرا عن خلل في العلاقات ما بين الجانبين
فاغنر وايضا القياده الدفاعيه الروسيه او
نتحدث عن خلاف حقيقي عميقا ماذا نتحدث هنا
لا اعلم
وطبيعتي تلك الخلافات التي نسمع عنها
والتي
قد بدات منذ اسبوعين او ثلاثه اسابيع بين
مجموعه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بصوره عامه
وقد تكون قد بدات مع نهايه حرب
المعركه في باخمت بسبب نقصه الذخيره انذاك
وارتبعتك
سيدعلم بطبيعه الخلاف الموجود ولكن حجم
هذا الخلاف كيف تقرا تاثير على الارض لانه
الخطاب ما بين الجانبين خرج عن مستوى
اللياقه اذا مصحه تعبير
ان هذا الامر يعزى لانجاز
التي كانت موكله اليها في في
وهناك نوع من الخلاف بين الوحدات العسكريه
من جهه وماجنر من جهه اخرى وقد يكون هناك
حاله من الصراع والنزاع على بعض مناصب
السلطه
وهذا قد يكون هو سبب الصراع لكن القوات
العسكريه بالاضافه الى
قوات الفاكنار
وكلهم بيعملون تحت عمره الرئيس بوتين في
نهايه الامر
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان كل هذه الت
قد تم حلها حسب اعتقادي
طيب
يعني
اخذ
رئيس الخبير العسكري الجنرال جنرال
دومينيك قراءتك للمشهد وهل برغم ما نشهد
من خلاف حتى ولو كان في الخطاب ما بين
الطرفين الا ان القرار النهائي هو للرئيس
الروسي وبالتالي اي خلافات اي خلل في
العلاقات لا يؤثر على الارض
اولا على دعوه وجهه النظر بانني مندهش
للغايه ان الجيش الروسي العظيم بحاجه الى
مرتزقه للقتال في دومباس ووجهه النظر ان
هذا الجيش لا يجب عليه ان يكون لديه روابط
مع مجموعه من المرتزقه من اجل تعزيز وضع
القوات في في قلب المعارك
ونتحدث عن الجيش الروسي قد يكون هناك ثمه
خطبا ما بين الرئيس بوتين وبين بريجوجن
لماذا يجب على الرئيس بوتين ان يدعم تلك
المجموعه
من المرتزقه واخراجها من السجون هذا امر
يبعث على المفاجاه فدوله كروسيا بتلك
الحجم ليست بحاجه الى هذه القوات جنرال
البعض ربما يرى ويقول انه حتى الدول
الاوروبيه وايضا الولايات المتحده في كثير
من الاحيان تستخدم اذرع عسكريه على الارض
ولا تواجه مباشره الحرب ولكن دعني اعود
الى النقطه الرئيسيه بغض النظر عن السبب
وراء استخدامهم هذه العلاقه ما بين
الطرفين كيف تقيمونها والى اي حد تعتقد
انها يمكن ان تؤثر على التطورات الميدانيه
على الارض
ان الرئيس
هو القائد العام للقوات المسلحه هو الذي
سوف تكون له الكلمه الطول في هذا الصراع
بصرف النظر عن كافه الخلافات وكافه الظروف
التي يعيشها الجيش الروسي
الكل كان يستمع لتصريحات بريجوجن واعتقد
ان هذا الامر كان قد تم تنظيمه عمدا من
اجل دفع القوات لتكون اكثر نشاطا وفعاليه
هذا ما احسبه ما احسبه على الاقل
ولماذا القوات الروسيه تحتاج الى هذه
القيمه المرتزقه
اعتقد انها تستخدمها لان بوتين لا يرغبوا
ده
بالقوات المجنده حديثا
ومعظمهم من الادن من المدنيين في تلك
المعارك اما اولئك فهم مستعدون ان يقاتلوا
حتى الموت فهم يتقادون اموالا لقاء ذلك
حول النقطه الرئيسيه بغض النظر عن السبب
الرئيسي ولكن هذا الخطاب ما بين الجانبين
التصعيدي الى اي حد يمكن ان يؤثر على
الميدان وبالمقابل الى احد الدول الغربيه
والاوروبيه معنيه بهذا الصراع وتنظر اليه
على انه ربما يكون ورقه يمكن استخدامها
نتحدث عن السيد
ومجموعه لكن السؤال هو كم عدد الميليشيات
الموجوده والمنخرطه هناك واذا لم يكن
لديكم السيطره كامله على تلك القوات لا
يمكنكم التحكم بالدوله والكلمات التي يدلي
بها السيد هي كلمات قاسيه بحق وزاره
الدفاع
ورئاسه هيئه الاركان
الوقت
بدفع المجندين حديثا الى المعركه واستخدام
المرتزقه بدلا منهم
كان معنا من باريس الخبير العسكري الجنرال
ترانكان ومن موسكو الكسندر كوزين صوف نائب
مدير معهد التنبؤ والتسويه السياسيه
لحالات الصراع شكرا جزيلا لكما
طبعا يوم بعد يوم تزداد تكهنات حول الهجوم
المضاد الواسع الذي تحضر له القوات
الاوكرانيه منذ اشهر من اجل صد القوات
الروسيه ومن اجل طردها ايضا من المناطق
شرقيه البلاد وفيما اكدت روسيا اليوم ان
كياب بدات بالفعل هذا الهجوم الواسع على
منطقه
طبعا يعم السكون الجانب الاوكراني بل ان
الجيش الاوكراني جدد مطالبته بالتزام
الصمت فيما يتعلق بتنفيذ هذا الهجوم الذي
طال انتظاره وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه قالت
ان الخطط تحب الصمت وانها لن تعلن ولن
تعلن عن بدء هذا الهجوم
على كل مشاهدينا على الرغم من عدم وضوح
الرؤيه فيما اذا كانت اوكرانيا بالفعل قد
بدات هجومها المضاد من عدمه دعونا نلقي
الضوء على ما حدث في الساعات الماضيه في
مقاطعه وفقا للروايه الروسيه الدفاع
الروسيه قالت انها صدت هجوما ضخما للقوات
الاوكرانيه عبر خمس نقاط جنوبي
دونيسك هي واحده من اربع مناطق اوكرانيه
ضمتها روسيا الخريف الماضي تشمل
لوغانسكون القوات الاوكرانيه طبعا بحسب
تصريحات الدفاع الروسيه استخدمت ست كتائب
ميكانيكيه وكتبتي دبابات في هذا الهجوم
وبينما نفث موسكو ان تكون كييف قد نجحت في
اختراق دفاعاتها في القطاع الاكثر ضعفا
حيث تتصاعد المواجهات منذ اشهر اكتفت
اوكرانيا والتي غيرت تكتيكاتها العسكريه
اخيرا بشن هجمات متفرقه داخل العمق الروسي
اكتفت باعلان تقدم قواتها البريه في
دونتسك وبالتحديد في موا قع قربه مدينه
باخموت التي فرضت قوات فاجنر الروسيه
السيطره عليها الشهر الماضي
[موسيقى]
هذا هو وسط تكهنات من طرفي الحرف في
اوكرانيا بشان الهجوم المضاد يبقى السؤال
ان كانت اكياب ستتحرك فعلا لاستعاده
اراضيها ام ان الامر برمته مجرد خطه وهميه
وحرب نفسيه تمارسها كيف ضدها موسكو نتابع
الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد لاستعاده الارض
وهزيمه الروس حقيقه عسكريه ام خطه وهميه
وحرب نفسيه
[تصفيق]
الرئيس الاوكراني قال لويس ريد جون ان
الهجوم المضاده جاهز وسيكون خلال اسابيع
يلا في رايي واعتبارا من اليوم نحن على
استعداد للقيام بذلك نود الحصول على معدات
معينه لكننا لا نستطيع الانتظار لشهود انا
مؤمن بقوه باننا سننجح لكن لا اعرف كم
سنحتاج من الوقت
مستشار زيلينسكي للشؤون الخارجيه استبعد
الخطه العسكريه وقال لصحيفه ان اوكرانيا
تفتقد لاسلحه تكفي لشن هجوم مضاد
[موسيقى]
الجيش الاوكراني نشر فيديو دعائيا اسمه
الخطط تحب الصمت يطلب فيه من المواطنين
عدم تصوير او افشاء اسرار التحركات
الميدانيه للجنود في العلوم العسكريه عاده
ما يبقى موعد الهجوم وخطته امرا سريا وهو
ما لا ينطبق على خطه اوكرانيا المعلنه في
شتى وسائل الاعلام الغربيه وعلى النقيض
فان وسائل الاعلام الروسيه تفند الهجوم
الاوكرانيه المزعوم يعتقدون في موسكو ان
الامر حرب نفسيه تسعى لزعزعه ثقه الجنود
الروس على الخطوط الاماميه وان هجوم
اوكرانيا المضاد لن يتعدى مسيرات وصواريخ
بعيده المدى تضرب العمق الروسي وهو ما
يحدث هذه الايام
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
المفوضيه الاوروبيه تقول ان تويتر اختارت
الصدام لعدم امتثالها لمكافحه المعلومات
المضلله
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه اعلن الجيش
السوداني استعاده قاعده النجوم الجويه
الجنوبيه العاصمه الخرطوم وذلك بعد معارك
عنيفه مع قوات الدعم السريع نتابع
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
هذا وقد اظهرت الصور تصاعد الدخان الكثيف
في سماء الخرطوم مع استمرار المواجهات بين
الجيش والدعم السريع نتابع
وفي ظل هذه التطورات الميدانيه توعد
الاتحاد الاوروبي بمحاسبه كافه المسؤولين
عن الانتهاكات والتجاوزات لحقوق الانسان
في السودان بعد ان رصد تجاوزات عده جراء
المواجهات حتى الاتحاد الاوروبي في بيان
طرفي الصراع في السودان على وقف الاعمال
القتاليه على الفور وافساح المجال
الاستئناف عمليه انتقال سياسي شامله ذات
مصداقيه مضيفا ان العمل متواصل مع جميع
الجهات الاقليميه والدوليه المعنيه بما في
ذلك الاتحاد الافريقي والممثل الخاص
للامين العام للامم المتحده في السودان
لتحقيق تلك الاهداف
نفى عضو من لجنه الليبيه المشتركه وجود اي
خلافات قد تعيق التوقيع على القوانين
الانتخابيه التي وافقت عليها اللجنه خلال
اجتماعاتها في المغرب قال عضو باللجنه في
تصريحات صحفيه ان البرلمان ملزم بالتوقيع
وان عمليه التصديق هي اجراء شكلي وفق
الاعلان الدستوري وان رئيس مجلس النواب
الليبي عقيله صالح ورئيس مجلس الدوله خالد
المشري في طريقهما الى مدينه ابو زنيقه
بالمغرب للتوقيع عليها واشار الى انه بعد
التوقيع على القوانين ستتم احالتها الى
المفوضيه العليا للانتخابات في ليبيا
وسيتم النظر في امكانيه اجراء الانتخابات
من عدمها بعد دراسه الاوضاع في البلاد
طبعا هذه التصريحات جاءت ردا على تقارير
اعلاميه ليبيا ذكرت طبعا نقلا عن مصدر
برلماني ان رئيس البرلمان عقيل صالح قد
يرفض التوقيع على القوانين الانتخابيه من
لجنه 6 + 6 بعد اتهام عدد من النواب
بتجاوز الصلاحيات بزياده عدد مقاعد
البرلمان
ومن ابو زنيقه حيث الاجتماعات ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه عادل الزبيري اهلا بك عادل
بدايه اين وصلت هذه الاجتماعات في توقيع
ما في توقيع متى سنستمع الى المؤتمر
الصحفي حول ذلك
مرحبا ميسون لا يزال الانتظار سيده الموقف
بحسب مصادر الحدء في عصر مصادر العربيه
خالد المشري وايضا عقيل صالح على وصول كما
تقود العباره العربيه الشهيره الى المغرب
وفي انتظارهما هنا في منتجع بوزنيقه في
ضواحي العاصمه المغربيه الرباط بحسب مصادر
العربيه الترتيبات جاهزه والتوافقات جاهزه
ولكن مصدرا مقربا من مكتب المستشار عقيل
صالح رئيس مجلس النواب الليبي اكد وجود
تحفظات على التفاهمات الليبيه الليبيه هنا
في بوزنيقه المغربيه بالتاكيد ان
المشاورات مستمره في الكواليس من اجل
انضاج تفاهمات الليبيه الليبيه
تتحول الى مقترح قانون يجري رفعه الى مجلس
النواب الليبي لان مصدر العربي يشير الى
ان مصادقه مجلس النواب الليبي ضروريه لكي
تاخذ هذه التفاهمات الليبيه الليبيه صفه
القانون الملزم كما ان هنالك تحفظا من قبل
جهات على اعتبار ان توقيت الانتخابات
الليبيه يجب الرجوع فيه الى اللجنه العليا
للانتخابات وان لجنه سته زائد سته هنا في
المغرب انتهى اجلها القانوني لانها لم
تعلن عن طلبي ولا عن الموافقه عن التمديد
اذا ننتظر لنعرف تفاصيل التفاهمات ونتاكد
من التسريبات التي وصلتنا هل هي التفاهمات
النهائيه هنا هنا في بوزنيقه سيداريوهان
اما التوقيع من طرف عقيل صالح وخالد
المشري او الاعلان رسميا عن هذه التفاهمات
بحضورهما لرمزيتهما ولانهما مؤسستان
ليبيتان معترف بهما بالاتفاق الصخيرات نعم
عندي سؤال ذكرت بعض التحفظات بس كان في
عناوين رئيسيه تابعناها فيما يتعلق بقضيه
مزدوجي الجنسيه وايضا فيما يتعلق
بالعسكريين هذه المواضيع حسمت
نعم ميسون حسمت هذه المواضيع جرى فتح
الباب امام ترشح الجميع سواء من مزدوج
الجنسيه شريطه تنازلهم على الجنسيه
الاجنبيه في حال فوزهم في الانتخابات
البرلمانيه او الرئاسيه الليبيه وفيما
يتعلق بالموضوع الثاني هي رموز النظام
الليبي القديم في اشاره الى صيف الاسلام
القذافي ايضا جرى تجاوز هذه النقطه
والسماح بترشح هذه الاسماء ايضا فيما
يتعلق بالشخصيات العسكريه جرى السماح لها
بالترشح شريطه استقالاتها من المنصب
العسكري بعد فوزها الدوره الاولى بس عادل
في سؤال ايضا يتعلق
بالاحتجاج 61 نائب على زياده اعداد النواب
هل هذا الملف لازال محل جدل ام ماذا
نعم هنالك رغبه من اللجنه هنا في المغرب
بالخروج بتوافقات ولكن يبدو ان هؤلاء
النواب عبروا عن عدم رضاهم عن ما جرى في
بوزنيقه هنالك ايضا احتجاج من الطرف
الثاني في طرابلس من خلايا التعبير عن عدم
الرضا اذا المفاوضات الليبيه الليبيه
اللجنه سته زائد سته في المغرب يمكن القول
انها لم تنال القبول والرضا والاجماع
الكامل من طرف الطبقه السياسيه ومن طرفي
مركزي الثقل في ليبيا وكلاهما عبر بطريقته
هنالك ايضا رغبه من الامم المتحده لتوسيع
دائره التمثيل الليبي وعدم اقصاء اي
حساسيه او اقليم جغرافي وهو ما دعى بحسب
البعض الى اقتراح برلمان ليبي من غرفتين
الزبيري شكرا جزيلا لك
نبقى في ليبيا ولكن في اطار وموضوع اخر
لاقت العمليه الامنيه التي اطلقتها حكومه
دبيبه في غرب ليبيا لمحاربه الخارجين عن
القانون وفق قولها باستخدام الطيران
المسير لاقت استهجان بعض الاطراف بحجه ان
المقصود منها ازاحه ما يعارضه سياسيا منير
الاشهب معه التفاصيل
ضربات جويه متتاليه باستخدام طيران مسير
على مواقع غرب ليبيا اعلنت حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه انتهاء مرحلتها الاولى والبدء في
المرحله الثانيه منها والتي تستهدف اوكار
الجريمه بحسب رئيس الحكومه
مواقع
خطوط التهريب وخطوط التهريب البشره وتهريب
البنزينه او دخول
الكوكايين والهيروين والمخدرات بجميع
انواعها خصومه يتهمونه باستغلال المطالب
الشعبيه لتحقيق اهداف سياسيه في ظل
التقارب بين مجلسين النواب والدوله حكومه
استغلت هذه المساله لاغراض اللي هي
تكسب بها رائعان جلعاده يعني كل حدث حتى
الاحداث النبيله تحاول تحولها
[موسيقى]
واحد منهم بيت نائب بيت نائب في مجلس
النواب تصفيه حسابات سياسيه هذا هو مدخل
منطقه ابو صره في مدينه الزاويه والتي كان
لها نصيب الاسد من القصف الجوي بالطيران
المسير الذي تديره حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
بطرابلس نقول انها قصفت مواقعا لتهريب
البشر والوقود فيما يقول معارضها ان
المواقع التي استهدفت هي لمعارضيه بيبه
فقط
عضو مجلس النواب عن المنطقه علي ابو زريبه
اكد في اكثر من مناسبه ان القصف استهدفه
بشكل شخصي بعد استضافته الاجتماع بين
اعضاء مجلسي النواب والدوله بمناقشه ملف
توحيد الحكومه تفاجا بضربه طيارات مسيره
على منزل الخاص
المنزل كان متواجد فيه عائلتي وابنائي
يتحدث مواطنون من داخل ابو صره على انهم
يؤيدون محاربه الجريمه في المنطقه الغربيه
بالكامل ولكنهم مثل قولهم يستغربون من
استهداف منطقتهم التي شهدت في فتره
الماضيه بناء بعض المرافق الحيويه التي
كانت تفتقر لها على حد قولهم نحن سكان
بصره نستنكر هذا العمل لان فعلا لا يوجد
ما يستدعي ضربات جويه للاماكن الامنه
نستغرب في الموضوع القصف اللي حصل لنا
وترعيب الاطفال وترعيب النساء وترعيب
الشيوخ يعني مش معقول طائره تقصفنا في
بصره
تاتي وتقصف منطقه سكانها امنون
في على سبه انك تحارب في الارهاب فهذا
والله الى الظلم في المنطقه اعربوا عن
خشيتهم من ارسال حكومه الوحده قوه بريه ما
يعني وفق قولهم عوده الاقتتال في المنطقه
الغربيه وسط تداخلات سياسيه وقبليه منير
الاشهب ليبيا العربيه
قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني قال ان السفاره
الايرانيه في السعوديه ستفتح ابوابها غدا
الثلاثاء كنعان اوضح انه سيتم اعاده فتح
ابواب السفاره الايرانيه في الرياض
والقنصليه الايرانيه العامه بجده خلال
يومي الثلاثاء والاربعاء بشكل رسمي اضافه
الى اعاده المندوب الدائم لايران لدى
منظمه التعاون الاسلامي في التوقيت نفسه
قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رفائيل غراسي قال انه طرح مع
الايرانيين نقطه اعاده تركيب وتشغيل اجهزه
المراقبه وايضا امكانيه الوصول الى
البيانات مشيرا الى ان توقيف ايران لاجهزه
المراقبه وايضا الكاميرات ادى الى وجود
فجوه بيانيه وذلك لمده عام تقريبا
اقترحت مع الايرانيين نقطه اعاده تركيب
اجهزه الرقابه وامكانيه الوصول الى بيانات
هذه الاجهزه وفي حال عدم وصولنا الى
البيانات من اجهزه الرقابه لن نستطيع
متابعه عملنا فعندما قررت ايران الصيف
الماضي فصل اجهزه المراقبه والكاميرات ادى
ذلك الى وجود فجوه بيانيه لمده عام تقريبا
قال في كلمه امام مجلس المحافظين ان
المعدات الالكترونيه التي تنوي الوكاله
الدوليه تنويه تركيبها داخل تلك المنشات
النوويه الايرانيه مفيده للحصول على
انطباع مباشر عما يجري بداخل تلك المنشات
نتابعه
الذين تاكدوا بان هناك درجات تخصيب عاليه
في ماده اليورانيوم كما تاكدوا ايضا ان
عمليه التنقيه ادت الى هذا المستوى العالي
من التخصيب والمعدات الالكترونيه التي
نحاول تركيبها داخل تلك المنشات هي مفيده
لتعطينا انطباعا مباشرا ان كانت هناك
عمليات تخصيب او غيرها
قيم الشفافيه
قالت ان تويتر اختار المواجهه بعد قراره
بترك مدونه الاتحاد الاوروبي لافضل
الممارسات الطوعيه ضد تضليل عبر الانترنت
وحذرت من ان الشبكه الاجتماعيه التي
يملكها ايلون ماسك سيتم فحصها عن كثب فيما
يخص الامتثال لقانون الاتحاد الاوروبي
والخدمات التي ستدخل حيز التنفيذ في
الخامس والعشرين من اغسطس
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
التحذيراته من الذكاء الاصطناعي تتوالى
روبوتات الدردشه قد تستخدم لتجنيد الشباب
لتنفيذ عمليات ارهابيه
اهلا بكم مجددا تغيب الامير هاري عن جلسه
بمقر المحكمه العليا في لندن تنظر في دعوه
رفعها ضد مؤسسه صحفيه بريطانيه تهمها
بانتهاك خصوصيته الشخصيه من جانبه عبر
القاضي الذي ينظر في القضيه عن اندهشه
لغياب الامير هاري في حين اعتبر احد
محاميل مؤسسه الصحفيه ان غيابه غير عادي
من المتوقع يدلي الامير هاري بشهادته على
منصه الشهود غدا ليصبح اول فرد رفيع
المستوى في الاسره المالكه البريطانيه
يدلي بشهادته امام محكمه منذ
30 عاما
[موسيقى]
الذكاء الاصطناعي باتا سلاحا ذو حدين فرغم
ان استخدامه قد يسهم في تحقيق نهضه على
المستويين العلمي وايضا على المستوى
الاقتصادي الا ان سلبياته بدات تتضح تباعا
وصلت حتى تهديد بقاء الجنس البشري اخر هذه
المخاطر هي ان تتحول روبوتات الدردشه
لاداه تحريض على الارهاب صحيفه الجارديان
نقلت عن مسؤول مراجعه تشريعات الارهاب في
بريطانيا قوله ان العالم ركز على ايجابيات
الذكاء الاصطناعي لكنه تجاهل كيفيه
استخدام الارهابيين لهذه التكنولوجيا
لتنفيذ هجمات اعترف المسؤول ان برامج
الدردشه لديها القدره على اقناع الافراد
المتعصبين بشن هجمات ارهابيه واما الاطفال
والمراهقين هما على راس قائمه المستهدفين
فخوره الذكاء الاصطناعي تكمن في امكانيه
الوصول السهل لهؤلاء الشباب حتى داخل غرف
نومهم ما دفع خبراء لا طلاق تحذيرات
بضروره التعلم من دروس الماضي حينما تحولت
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي الى مصدر رئيسي
لتبادل المحتوى الارهابي
ينضم الينا من سان فرانسيسكو عبر سكايب
دكتور احمد بنافع استاذ الهندسه وامن
الشبكات في جامعه سانهوزيه الحكوميه اهلا
بك دكتور اسمح لي ان ابدا بما نسمعه الان
من مخاطر حول
الذكاء الاصطناعي والتركيز على المخاطر
تحديدا هل هذا شيء طبيعي حمله توعويه
طبيعيه تحذيرات طبيعيه او لا هناك هجمه
اعلاميه في يبدو تركز على الجانب السلبي
من الذكاء الاصطناعي
سؤال جيد جدا احنا تعلمنا من الماضي مثل
ما ذكرته في التقرير
التواصل المنصات للتواصل الاجتماعي كانت
في البدايه يعني فرحه للجميع انهم
بيتواصلوا مع الجميع بعدين وجدنا عن في
اثار الجانبيه مثل ما اتذكر التقرير هنا
في مخاطر كبيره عشان كذا من الفتره اللي
فاتت كانت في رسالتين وثيقتين وقعتهم هما
طالب بانه يكون تدخل الحكومه تكون في
رقابه على الذكاء الاصطناعي حتى ما يتمادى
في المجال هذا نعم ولكن بغض النظر عن ذلك
دكتور من يقف وراء هذه الحملات المتكرره
لانه بحسب ما اشعر بالفتره الاخيره وكانها
مكثفه هو الوعي ودراسه ما حدث بالماضي
بالفعل او انه لا هناك جهات ربما معارضه
للذكاء الاصطناعي ايضا تريد تحريك الملف
بطريقتها الخاصه هو خليط من الاثنين اختي
الكريمه في واحد من العلماء او واحد من
المهندسين المشهورين كان يشتغل في جوجل
كان يعتبروه هو يعني ابو الذكاء الاصطناعي
استقال من جوجل عشان ينضم للجهه اللي
بتطالب بالنظر في الذكاء الاصطناعي
المخاطر ما حتحصل مثلا بشكل يعني في
المستقبل القريب باستثناء الموضوع اللي
ذكرتوه عن الارهاب اللي هو فعلا خطر هذا
ممكن يحصل في المستقبل القريب نتكلم على
يعني على سنوات قادمه فهم الان دكتور احمد
كيف ممكن يصيروا عندما نقول انه يجب
الانتباه مين الاهل بالبيت ام انه في
امكانيه للحد من ذلك بينما اذا ما عدنا
بالوراء صلاه الدردشه او غرف الدردشه لم
تحمي اطفالنا في البدايه
المسؤوليه تقع على عده جهات اولا على
الشركه المنتجه بحيث انها تكون فيها ضوابط
اخلاقيه من البرمجه هذه ما هي صعبه يعني
بامكانهم انهم يضبطوها من ناحيه الكلمات
ومن ناحيه السياق ومن ناحيه الاتصالات
الثانيه من ناحيه الحكومه والحكومات يعني
لو في واحد من البرامج الدردشه
الالكترونيه او الذكاء الاصطناعي هذه
تجاوزت الحدود وحصلت يعني لا قدر الله
حادثه او شيء ممكن يفرضوا عقوبات ويمنعوها
ويمنعوا هذا البرنامج
تعال بسبب الذكاء الاصطناعي وسرعته
وسهولته للوصول الى هؤلاء ان يكون هناك
بالفعل عمليات ارهابيه قادمه
على حسب التقارير اللي اللي وردت منها
الجار اللي ذكرتوه كمان في تقارير ثانيه
حصلت على انه مثل ما انت بتطلب من الذكاء
الاصطناعي من تشاء مثلا انه يكتب ايميل
باللغه المحليه والايميل هذا مقنع حتطلب
منه ان يكتب رساله او او تفصيل او خطوات
مثلا حيث يقنع الاشخاص بعقليتهم بمستواهم
يعني انا من الاشياء اللي شفتها يا اختي
الكلمه انك انت ممكن تطلب من ذكاء
الاصطناعي نكتب ايميل بمستوى الثانوي
مستوى مثلا سنه اولى جامعه على اساس ان
الشخص هذا يستوعبه وهذه خطورته نعم
الدكتور احمد بنافع استاذ الهندسه وامن
الشبكات في جامعه سانكوسيا الحكوميه شكرا
جزيلا لك
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
الولايات المتحده اتهمها بالتسبب في
المتاعب وخلق المشاكل في مضيق تايوان
تسبب الجانب الامريكي في المتاعب
والاستفزاز بينما تعامل الجانب الصيني
معها وفقا للقانون وكانت المبادره التي
اتخذها الجيش الصيني قانونيه واحترافيه
ويجب على الجانب الامريكي ان يفكر بعمق
ويصحح الاخطاء
اقوم بمناورات بالقرب من مدمره امريكيه في
مضيق تايوان اتهمت بكين بتنفيذ مناورات
غير امنه بالمنطقه
[موسيقى]
اعلن مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه ان المنظمه وكالات اغاثه خفضت
ميزانيه خطه المساعدات لافغانستان هذا
العام الى 3.2 مليار دولار بدلا من 4.6
مليار دولار الامم المتحده ارجعت قرار
التخفيض الى القيود التي فرضتها حكومه
طالبان على عمل النساء في مجال الاغاثه
وبهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه الخامس
شكرا للمتابعه مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات